yo what's up YouTube it's Mike Williams
he might also know me as yoga roomie
alright so I'm super excited to talk to
you about something today and that's a
side project I built and he's probably
got two years ago now but it's called
studio time you might have heard of it
we've been picked up by press since then
literally from the first week of launch
we generated million hits the site in
ten dollars in revenue and week's video
Tom it's probably the best thing to
happen to a musician in a very long time
I went on the website took me two
minutes and I was put into this studio
here so I'm gonna talk to you on this
video about first off how I came up with
the idea and validated in so quickly
second off that initial MVP and what I
use to build it and then where I
launched and how the launch went all
right so let's get started so I'm gonna
talk to you first about how I came up
with the concept and built it so quickly
I came up the concept after I saw a lot
of friends in the music industry that
literally were texting other friends and
maybe this is managers other producers
engineers other artists and they were
saying all right like what Studios
around you know what's the rave path
artists equipment all these kind of like
different factors that were involved
with running a music studio and how
could they book them I knew that there
needed to be a better way to do it so I
wanted to build it now first thing I did
once I knew there is an existing need
for something like this while I was like
someone had built this idea right this
is during the time of like Airbnb 4x4
everything for literally like dog
walkers and literally everything you can
think of right what I did was I made a
product I'm so I'll link down here below
to product hunt but this is a place
where a lot of people launch products
before they actually become companies so
well like side projects exactly what I
was going to build to my amazement no
one had built this idea at least from
what I what I tried to see so I knew all
right I'm gonna cancel a dinner it was
literally this is one evening and I was
like I have to build this because
someone else is what did I do the steps
as far as to build it first thing I did
was I needed to come up with a name and
do some kind of link branding and come
up with a logo and so forth because I
to identify who we are and kind of what
we're doing that resonates with this
alright first thing I did or I guess
thing that came to my mind was studio
time so I literally just went to go
Daddy and started like plugging into
mains studio time calm all right taken
ok so what's the next thing studio time
dot IO a little bit more $59.99 a year
but I was like done click the Buy
I had mines made from there next thing I
did was I use Squarespace logo generator
so this is great it's literally like a
WYSIWYG tool where you can create a logo
easily in minutes and it's about $5.99
or $9.99 for a commercial license which
we were going to be accompanying
potentially so I click purchase on that
and I have my logo so I didn't have to
sketch Photoshop any other kind of more
robust design tools I simply did this
with in browser on Squarespace logo
generator so obviously I'll link down
that below - alright so I had the name
logo then next what I had to do was try
to find some pre-existing technology
platform or tools for getting the
technical component of a marketplace and
try to leverage that as much as possible
so I didn't want to build anything from
scratch on this it totally didn't make
sense because I had like an evening to
literally take this idea that I had that
was in my head and get it out there fast
so I found sharetribe
which I'll go into more if you guys want
just comment below and I can go in a
totally just talk about sharetribe and
how I pack the platform up to use it for
my needs and studio time in other
marketplaces for me and then other
companies now that I've scaled but it's
a great tool to use in literally within
30 minutes to an hour you can build the
basics of a marketplace so think like an
Etsy for X and Airbnb for X kind of
marketplaces so I got the first first
one first MVP of this thing built in
about 30 minutes to an hour on
sharetribe now a lot of people will know
it was functional from user side so to
list the studio if you're a music studio
or discover based off location or other
criteria music studios around you basic
profiles but when you click request
studio the payments actually didn't work
why because I didn't have
time to get it hooked up but I wanted to
just go ahead and put it out live in
domain and try to build some inventory
and demand and see if people even wanted
to use this site first before I spent a
lot of time actually building out more
robust functionality that was not part
of the initial user experience so now
that I had that then what I wanted to do
is take this initial prototype and
validate it quickly this was I think on
a Thursday it was kind of a race against
a clock because I wanted to get this out
there quickly and just get some kind of
signaling and validation like is this a
great idea or not all right people going
to tell me what I did was I needed to
build inventory so actually searched on
Craigslist based in LA and then New York
City I wanted to see what our studios
will first off our music studios
creating listings on Craigslist to rent
their spaces they work which is amazing
I've looked at their descriptions and
their pictures and I said okay how do I
compare this aside to the studio time
profiles for our studios so I added a
few fields in there that I didn't
initially count for why because I wasn't
an industry professional so I had to get
some more validation from how this is
actually working pre-existing liebe for
studio time so this is on the weekend so
I made a few changes and then I actually
found the phone numbers when you click
reply on Craigslist to some of these
studios and I literally text them I said
hey I'm building this new concept and
air being me for music studio is kind of
site would you list your studio on here
and then I made it free for them and
they're like yes I probably sent out
about 45 or 50 of these initial texts
but I got my first three to five studios
that weekend
now what did I do from there how do I
get taken to the next step I actually
went on Twitter and I found people that
were looking or talking about music
studios so what I wanted to do was
identify where is the conversation
taking place about music studios now I
tweeted out them I tweeted the link to
the site I got the site Twitter account
set up then I went and not a count liked
it from that so I wanted to try to gain
a little bit of engagement on that and
get their attention and say hey what a
studio time so I got a couple of users
from there so now I had inventory and I
had users there was a
an actual liquidity of them wanting to
book these music studios yet but I
hadn't even launched and this was in
like 48 hours of me building a prototype
alright next I knew I was gonna launch
our own product ton because for me that
was a great place to launch it and first
off get some kind of feedback from other
people who have built other market
places so on product time this is where
a lot of investors a lot of other
founders a lot of other developers
product managers that do build side
projects and have built successful
companies this is where they launch
products and like to look at products
early and be the first to know so I
watched Monday morning and honestly it
was pretty wild thankfully for me a lot
of people in the tech industry are also
super passionate about music so I was in
business I got a lot of great feedback I
didn't get a ton of upvotes it was
around 200 I think upvotes
which you know you get some products on
product on that literally have thousands
of up votes and generates a ton of
traffic because they might be like SAS
tools or other kind of very tech focused
products
mine was a marketplace for music studios
amazing thing from this was we did get a
lot of people that were interested in
simply signed up and you know I got a
lot of feedback from other founders in
the tech industry like hey great
concepts and you know I just used the
kind of astounding boards to kind of
bounce off ideas about the product my
vision and whatnot but just keep in mind
it was a side project there was
literally no real kind of big scale
validation now where that came in was we
actually got picked up by fad because a
lot of PR at the time was from music was
checking product ton I'm assuming
because fax wrote an article and they
and they posted it and literally it we
just blew up
I mean honestly we had thousands of
people that hit the site from there if
they actually gave us the tagline to the
actual article but they are the ones
that calls the air BB for music studios
so literally crazy story the rest is
history from there because once fact
picked us up then everyone wanted this
story about who we are and what we're
doing the funny thing is it was just me
so I literally just built this in an
evening canceled dinner and now I had
this marketplace side project that I
thought could be a big company funny
enough I actually told that story to
hypebeast
I'll link down here below and probably
show a screenshot here in
get to that article and I literally said
hey cancel dinner built this website the
rest is history from there I actually
used kind of a processor not kind of I
did use a process around how do I build
momentum from this initial PR in this
kind of initial growth that we got from
product time we had our first few
thousand users I needed to drive actual
acquittee validate and get bookings so
what I did from there I use this process
of actual manually driving a lot of
demand for the studios so I had some
initial inventory I think like 30 to 50
studios that kind of trickled in but I
need to go to artists and managers I
need to identify the people that were
actually intending to book a studio and
I would go reach out to them and I would
kind of act as a concierge the first few
bookings
what kind of bookings did we drive and
what kind of studios were those for now
the crazy thing is I didn't know what
kind of studios we're gonna sign up for
this site so we had a lot of top-line
studios you know a few thousand dollars
a day but believe it or not we had home
studios that sign up to the site I
almost deleted them because I wasn't
sure that first often people actually
really want to book from studios or will
it be good to have that kind of
inventory on the site so early when it's
critical to build a brand image also at
the same time based off our inventory
thankfully we actually booked the first
studio I think was like $20 an hour and
it was a studio apartment that had a
home studio in Brooklyn from there I was
like wow this is amazing
I talked to them and they said hey
listen we can't use another site or
there's not another site that provides
this for us so at that point I knew I
was in business because I built a
product that serves a need for a segment
of the market which was actually kind of
the lower level economy as the market
that I could either go to and help them
grow their businesses all right so
that's the initial story of studio time
and we got a first thousand users from
this literally within a matter of hours
after the product on launch still within
a week of me coming up with the idea we
generated over $10,000 in revenue from
bookings and some subscriptions me
place literally within months and we
actually launched this into its own
company for studio time I gave you a
little story about this but I actually
want to know what do you want me to talk
about next in these other videos is it
about how we manage the inventory side
to build Studios generate more demands
in a market place is it how we navigated
the music tech landscape what is it you
let me know and I will make my next
video on that within a week or at most
two weeks I can't promise that super
busy I want to make more time for
YouTube so hit the subscribe button
below and I'll let you know more about
what I'm doing
Thanks
[Music]